[Music]
so on one hand it's nice that you can
look back at your previous work and see
a difference and actually know that
you're getting better at something but
on the other hand it is kind of
embarrassing when all that old stuff is
still up and it's just not good but i've
been making videos more or less for
about 13 years or almost 14 years now
which is crazy to say out loud but the
thing that i think i'm most proud of as
far as the video making process is that
pretty much all of it is self-taught
there is no how-to guide for
creating a tech channel and making
videos and and making a business out of
it until now we basically have created
the blueprint i got to basically
crystallize this blueprint in the form
of a master class i actually got to make
a master class which is pretty amazing
it's in pretty special company i mean
i've watched neil degrasse tyson's class
and then i got to talk to him in person
we just watched steph curry win an nba
championship with the warriors and he
did a master class and so to celebrate
i'm going to go back and look at my
older videos
or at least i'll go back in time slowly
and try to survive the cringe i'll
review them a bit maybe shed some light
on uh the behind the scenes process on
some of the stuff that we did to make it
happen
uh and we'll see how far we get back as
they get increasingly more and more old
let's do it all right so this first
video i'm going back to is already
october 2020 so it's about two years old
this is the sony xperia one mark ii
reviews of smartphones has kind of
become the bread and butter of the
channel and i've definitely noticed that
stepping outside of that a little bit
more has been more fun lately and this
is one of those videos snapdragon 865
eight gigs of ram a 21x9 widescreen
display triple cameras a 4 000 milliamp
hour battery really it's like
smartphones have gotten
so
consistent and a lot of people just say
boring which makes a lot of sense for
this video it's like the first
two minutes of it is just quickly
explaining what this exact phone is but
then we jumped right into all the more
interesting questions about like why
this sony phone if you didn't already
notice the two in the background the two
lights that's for the xperia one mark ii
there's there's always some easter egg
in every video fine but you know
technically anybody can build that
but the thing is this phone also has a
bunch of other stuff unique really
useful stuff that i haven't seen in any
other phone but all this stuff leads to
one question which is
why don't more people buy these okay so
this video so this is why don't people
buy sony's phones from two years ago it
has
7.1
million views and i just tweeted this
the other day because it was so
interesting like i like the phones and i
talk about them but these videos average
more views per
video about the phone than like any
other brand i found it funny because
they they still have like zero percent
market share but there's just a couple
factors in between sony actually getting
real customers
and not one of them being the fact that
there's like months between when they
announce the phone and it comes out the
other one being that it's fifteen
hundred dollars it's frustrating because
it seems like sony's kind of suffering
from some of the same stuff lg has
lately anyway which is their inability
to rip lg
all right i think we can go older okay
so this video here is the samsung galaxy
fold unboxing from 2019 23 million views
the recent unboxing of the samsung
galaxy fold that's a cool box this is an
interesting one this is the first
foldable phone that's really going on
sale to the masses it's priced way
higher than even any other high-end
samsung flagship so it's clearly
positioned as a luxury device so this
this video style is pretty similar still
to you know three years ago to now it's
close the funny behind the scenes story
about the fold though that i i've kind
of told but maybe i'll just put it all
in one place here uh you guys already
know it broke and there was lots of
stories that came out about it i
actually got a shot
of me peeling the screen protector off
and it breaking on camera but it never
made it to the internet because what
happened was i'd shot this whole
unboxing and first impressions video and
the magnet paper and all that fun stuff
and then as i was editing it i said oh
you know what i didn't get a shot yet of
taking the screen protector off so i set
up the camera
and got the shot of peeling the screen
protector and
got it i mean it shut down as i was
peeling it off so i had that shot and i
said oh that's bad well let me get back
to that so i finished editing the
unboxing video
published that
and then the next day i'm like trying to
figure out what happened to the screen
and then another person on twitter
saying hey me too hey me too and so i
chimed in on twitter hey mine also broke
and that's when the avalanche of galaxy
fold screen breaking
stuff happened there were very very few
review units this is one of them they
were all taken back
so there's a magnet in each side of the
galaxy fold about two thirds of the way
down as demonstrated by this magnet
paper the magnet paper is so
it's just so fun it's evergreen everyone
likes seeing where the magnets are in
things and this paper every time i use
it
in it in a instagram post and a tick
tock even
it's just fun we just like the magnet
paper so they're so strong that they
have a bit of a field effectively
outside of the phone itself strong
enough to pick up metal objects and
things like that yeah i remember that a
bunch of washers
nails or even whole bags of nails
what a weird feature
and i even had a small wrench that
worked and an apple pencil which of
course has a piece of metal in it for
the ipad's magnet that worked and a
really really big allen key it's made of
metal and it can pick it up this magnet
is for real so just have to share that a
little proof from what i was talking
about from the last video so you can see
in the background this is in the old
studio we're in a different part of the
same building now but i
i can picture
almost with photographic memory exactly
where everything in this old studio was
until we moved out the retro tech
episode 1
on the original game boy it's a good
time to be a video nerd either way
thanks for watching okay so the clock in
the background or the little screen as
you can see
8 million 304 962 subscribers that was a
a live counter at that time when youtube
didn't round now they just round to the
nearest
this would say 8.3 but
they used to actually tell you how many
catch you guys in the next one
peace
still similar in style i've had the same
camera stuff setups i've used a lot of
the same lenses since 2019 so i think we
can go even older so this is the htc u
ultra rant slash review from 2017 i mean
it's my channel i'm i get to talk about
the things that i like and that i'm
interested in and so the process for
like deciding what to make videos about
is like when something is so cool or so
good that i i want to talk about it then
it gets a video
and then there's this like gray area in
between and then there's the stuff
that's so bad
that it needs like a psa or people need
to know not to buy it yeah if you don't
think i did negative videos you should
probably watch this one
[Music]
i remember this notch this weird side
what's up guys i'm kittyhd here and this
is the brand new htc i don't know why i
look different
it's probably the lack of oh it's the
beard that's what it is yeah it's
definitely the beard
you ultra and it is definitely the
shiniest phone of all time and this
happens to also be htc's first big
smartphone of 2017 and it's coming to
the us with a price tag of
749 so this is definitely a that used to
be a lot of money for a smartphone the
galaxy note 7 nice little clean top-down
shot which stands for extra large and
it's bigger than all of those and even
others with even smaller displays it's
bigger than all of them and it's still
eight millimeters thick so it's also
definitely not trying to be a super thin
phone in any way either so okay so this
these shots here this is what we used to
do a little bit more often before we had
enough of a studio space to really make
a large variety of shots we'd use this
thing called breather which is it's
originally supposed to let people just
rent a space in the city and just like
take a breather or study or read or hang
out and they all looked kind of cool
and cooler than our studio so i would
use this as a like mobile video studio
that pop-up new york city and the
portless future isn't quite here yet and
htc you definitely could have also but
you didn't for some reason seems like a
poor use of space and then the battery
the htc u ultra has a 3 000 milliamp
hour battery which doesn't seem that bad
but for context
yeah something's a little bit off here
i love this i mean this is one of my
favorite videos to put together not
because i like trashing on phones but
this is one of the earlier times in a
video in a review or something like this
where i i spend an extra bit of effort
to make sure that there's a common
thread throughout the video a really
poor use of space poor use of space
seems like a poor use of space seems
like a poor use of space for your space
this doesn't always work with phones or
reviews at all but when it does it's
great for obviously retention and for
enjoying the video the whole way through
because you know what you come away from
the video with that i'll say skip this
one and you could pretty easily wait for
the htc 11 to come out pretty soon or
just grab a galaxy s8 when that comes
out or an lg g6 or pretty much any other
700 smartphone which will be a better
use of space than this one so that's
been it hope you enjoy
yeah there's been uh there's been quite
a few videos
uh with
said tone in the past no big deal
there's a there's a lot of fun of trying
to figure out you know trying to toe the
line between what to talk about not to
talk about all right let's get older
this is the most nervous i think i've
ever been in my life so this is in 2015
and it's it's kind of out of the blue
and random for the channel i've been
talking about tech and gadgets and
handheld stuff and along comes this
email from nike saying hey kobe bryant's
releasing a new signature shoe this is
in the middle of his farewell tour in
his legendary final nba season
and uh there's some tech in it and
we figure it would be cool to invite you
to come talk to him about it you down
what okay sure of course yeah i don't
know if i still don't think i'm that
good of an interviewer but
this is what the talking tech series
since then is this is what it's all
about from a tech perspective you know
i've i've kind of tried to dabble into
it a little bit but i found myself not
being extremely passionate about it um
unless it's centered around sports
right and things that involve um health
training
um
things of that sort
but overall i wouldn't describe myself
as a very tech savvy person
love the brutal honesty this is the
thing about kobe like when he cares
about something he dives into it i have
no idea yeah with a cd player star
struck that let alone a walk man it was
like wait you had to rewind what
yeah wait so that song was over you had
to flip it over and like use the other
side of the tape yeah yeah yeah so you
know um when i first came in lee
the world was such a different place
this is also this is a three camera
shoot i remember we took three cameras
out there i shot um with a friend john
from tld today awesome with making
videos
and this is also
the last video that i ever edited in
adobe premiere shoe b-roll the shoe must
it's harder than phone bureau when
you're used to phone b-roll
but it's the same shot in my hand
some free technology we've combined some
of the zoom and lunar technology would
have been some of the staples with some
of my other shoes
but they normally behave in isolation
they normally don't communicate with
each other this is like way more
in-depth information that i actually
thought i would get normally you get
someone who's like doing a sort of a
promo tour and they're just like oh yeah
watch my new movie oh yeah buy my new
product he's literally explaining how
like nike flyknit works with the ankle
of the shoe and how he has more torque
around the heel but less around the
sides so there's mobility with the shoe
it's crazy thanks for being a part of
this i appreciate the time uh and
hopefully we get to do it again thank
you awesome
that's that was the first of like the
interviews that i ever did in hindsight
i feel like i have a lot to thank kobe
for i mean i obviously that was the only
time i ever met him i remember when i
first we went to go set up the video
stuff and the guy was like alright yeah
so kobe when he walks in he's going to
go and go over to the left he's going to
do this interview then he's going to go
over here and do this interview then
he's going to come to you and do that
interview
and then he's going to head out my
heart's in my throat he comes over and
he's the nicest guy and he helps sort of
break the ice and i heard you doing this
youtube thing this is cool let's talk
about tech incredible we need more guys
like him all right this is we're going
back to 2014 now so this is a in case it
looks kind of crazy already this is a
video i shot in collaboration with the
verges video team they have an amazing
video team they still do to this day but
this is like the
they're in their prime of like this
crazy ultra wide video and and you know
a very recognizable style with motion
graphics so this is a collab shoot also
uh my hand is broken because uh as you
can see there's uh some stitches that i
and practice uh i just broke my hand
like a week or two before i shot this
it's fine though we could still shoot a
video kind of like the galaxy note 4 and
i take the finish from the nokia lumia
series so that's motion graphics instead
of a rawness soft touch is obviously
easier to hold than 2014 this was state
of the art it's funny that five and a
half inches was a massive display back
then and now i think the mini iphone is
just a little smaller than that so
inside we got to have top-notch specs so
here in late 2014 that means yeah what
is that four snapdragon 805 three gigs
of ram
uh the adreno 420 gpu basically the
whole deal so for the battery
the whole deal
i uh i'm reviewing a phone right now
with 18 gigs of ram just for context
empowers you better
did you see that fully translated in a
dream phone i'd be okay with anything 3
500 milliamp hours or better
this
it says this transition we were using if
you pause it at the right place it says
film impact demo on the right here is an
lg ad
and then on the right here is a samsung
phone ad and the next shot there's a
google android ad these things are
everywhere i think that's why we shot
this year because i said oh for the
operating system android but also i'm
shooting this right around times square
and i have if you look over the left
side of the frame that tall billboard
very recently we just got a team c's
billboard put on that exact super tall
billboard where the ball drops in times
square i also have a shot of my own face
on a time square billboard recently it's
crazy how that works out there's just
pigeons flying behind me
and then the verge mq bhd collapse see
that was kind of neat all right so now
we're going
we're going really really far into the
archives here this is where the cringe
really hits so this is 2009
[Music]
okay so
i can explain i can explain it's hard to
explain but i can explain even today i
still have a short intro before the
video so it was like you could make a
short animation with some free tools and
i wasn't skilled with video editing so i
was just using free tools so this thing
called animoto you could put in a couple
of photos it would create this
animation for you so i didn't
[Music]
this is the first
place i ever made videos which is in the
corner of my bedroom and my parents
house i'm on the webcam of the first
computer i ever had which was the hp
pavilion dv7t i used this computer for
like the first 400 videos so what i'm
gonna go into is that right now i have
i'm gonna check right now right now i
have approximately 70 sound like elmo
just gonna put that out there
if i go to my page youtube.com marcus
brownlee just click on the link over
there i have 74 subscribers i clearly
was not making money from this had no
intentions of this being my job at any
point it was just a fun thing i enjoyed
doing when i got back from practice i'm
literally like wearing my hoodie from
after practice before i had to go do my
homework i would just like make a video
because it was fun
what else can i tell you i mean
video 100 uploading more i've run out of
things to say stay tuned for more
battery tips i'm still uploading more
battery tips for you guys i ran out of
things to say
it was actually back in the day when uh
i used to get an email for every single
person who ever subscribed to the
channel and when they did i would click
on their profile and i would leave a
message thanking them for subscribing
yeah alright that's basically it so uh
thanks for watching subscribe and stay
tuned for more and i hope you like this
video peace peace never never didn't
have that let's go all the way back this
is the best place to end it here we go
um
bought a new laptop
and
literally this is the so this is the
first video i ever made january 2009 i
turn on the laptop webcam and i just
start talking and then i realize that my
glasses are reflecting the laptop screen
and i just take them off i just panic
and take them off i don't know who told
me to put my collar like that okay so
yeah
quite a nice remote so quite a nice
video center remote this is like those
old makeup tutorials where you got to
hold it up to the camera like this
because there's auto focus i don't know
if i can make it through the whole video
without cringing let's try um these
i'm like struggling with like the fact
that it reverses so when i move left it
moves right so i move back to try to
keep it in the frame fast forward you're
playing media controls yes it's a media
player remote oh no it's pretty handy i
it fits in your pocket quite easily it's
as you can see i have a big hand but
it's pretty small wow i said that in the
first video leave comments
and
subscribe thanks that was fun i hope
we'll probably do this again some some
future version where i look back at 2020
videos and cringe but hey until then
this has been it if you want to check
out the master class link below that'll
also be there
but uh yeah thanks for hanging around
and sticking to this and subscribing and
being here for the videos guys
catch you in the next one
peace
[Music]
love a train horn